jean marc bonjour alors plein de
questions est d'abord celle que tout le
monde se pose peut-on croire le ministre
de l'économie dans la conjoncture
actuelle on le croit qu'en technique qui
va y avoir des baisses d'impôts je crois
que les promesses n'engagent que ceux
qui les entendent
mais honnêtement oui on peut le croire
bruno le maire il n'y aura pas de hausse
d'impôt dans l'immédiat parce que toute
la stratégie du gouvernement en matière
économique passe par une relance des
entreprises et que les entreprises ont
besoin de marges elles ont besoin
d'oxygène
il faut que l'appareil économique
redémarre qu'il soit capable de gérer la
mutations engendrées par le cos vide 19
capable de générer de la croissance pour
créer des emplois alors le gouvernement
va dépenser
on le sait maintenant 100 milliards pour
financer la réindustrialisation la
transition écologique l'emploi parce que
l'emploi est menacé dans beaucoup de
secteurs et puis aussi la solidarité
sociale
une partie de ces 100 milliards ou va
passer par des restes d'un pot et
notamment on ne saura précisément demain
les impôts de production environ 10
milliards de baisse dans un premier
temps sur un total de 120 à 150
pratiquement entre 120 et 150 milliards
ce qui est très important
et puis il y aura sans doute les baisses
d'impôts sur les bénéfices des sociétés
qui étaient déjà programmés dans les
budgets précédents clap elle que ces 100
milliards s'ajoutent au crédit qui
avaient été mobilisés au moment du
confinement en mars pour mettre tout
l'appareil de production dans un coma
artificiel et surtout pour préserver son
fonctionnement pour le jour où il se
réveillerait alors on le voit la presque
totalité des fonds alloués de l'effort
du gouvernement a été repêché au
bénéfice des entreprises c'est que pure
logique d'offre comme disent les
économistes le gouvernement ne peut pas
changer de stratégie qui correspond
d'ailleurs à ce que font les autres
grands pays occidentaux
augmenter les impôts alors que nous
avons déjà des taux d'imposition parmi
les plus élevés de tous les pays de l'
ocde
c'est impossible à imaginer puis changer
de stratégie pour quoi faire
pourquoi faire une relance par la
demande diront certains mais la demande
existe il y a du pouvoir d'achat dans ce
pays très inégalitaire man ray partie
certes mais il existe il ya des comptes
courants qui n'ont jamais été aussi
remplie 400 milliards d'euros il y adeux
les pagnes beaucoup d
y compris de l'epagne très populaire
dans les caisses d'epargne beaucoup de
cash aussi qui ressort des bas de laine
c'est la preuve que les français ont
beaucoup d'épargné y compris les
français défavorisés et pas de
précaution c'est un marqueur de la peur
et ça c'est un problème c'est un
problème parce que on aura besoin que
les consommateurs consomment plus les
entreprises auront besoin de clients
il va donc falloir que six entreprises
fassent des offres désirable des offres
alléchantes pour attirer scheer
alors d'accord pas de hausses d'impôts
mais des baisses donc question comment
va-t-on financer des milliards d'argent
public qu'on distribue et oui parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'argent magique
il faut savoir que tout cet argent ne
sort pas du budget une partie ce sont
des prêts ce sont des prêts garantis par
l'état mais ça veut dire que les
entreprises vont devoir les rembourser
alors on sait pas très précisément si
toutes les entreprises pourront le faire
c'est d'ailleurs un problème pour dans
six mois pour dans un an
sinon c'est l'état qui sera de sa poche
et la poche de l'état passé la nôtre une
partie de ces fonds pour venir de
l'europe ça ça a été dit les 40 ou 50
milliards de prêts européens
et puis vous avez un bon tiers qui va
venir du budget mais comme le budget est
en déficit on le sait bien eh bien on va
faire de la tête de la dette publique on
va aller chercher une partie de
l'épargné français les obligations
d'état via les assurances vie il ya
beaucoup en stock on vient d'en parler
lien à l'instant donc globalement c'est
de la dette
et cette dette ne coûte pas très cher
actuellement dans la conjoncture puis
vous avez raison si la croissance n'est
pas au rendez vous à la fin de l'année
où l'année prochaine et bien si les
entreprises ne produisent pas de
richesse on va se sentir très bon on va
être très mal parce que notre
endettement ce moment là ne sera plus
garanti et un tel équilibre est risqué
ou pas pour le pouvoir politique
oui oui bien sûr quand monsieur quand on
n'y a pas de solution économique à un
problème quand vous avez du chômage on
vous avait une crise sociale est
derrière la crise sociale vient vous
avez forcément une crise politique dont
on ne sait pas comment elle peut se
résoudre
alors si les plans de relance ne marche
pas si l'opinion demande des comptes
elle demandera des comptes à l'état
d'abord ce qu'elle fait déjà elle
demandera des comptes aux grandes
entreprises
renault et air france qu'avez vous fait
de toutes ces entreprises si ça ne
marche pas l'opinion demandera aux chefs
d'entreprise ce qu'elles ont fait de
tout cet argent
la clé c'est donc la croissance avec la
croissance vous avez des emplois et vous
avez de quoi
éponger les dettes mais la croissance
dépend de poils et dépend de la
confiance ça dépend de l'argent bien sûr
mais ça dépend surtout de la confiance
actuellement
le contrat de confiance est cassé enfin
il est en partie cassé faut dire que ce
contrat dépend beaucoup de la situation
sanitaire et on en revient au virus
on en revient aux vaccins au traitement
que tout le monde attend on en revient
enfin vers un gouvernement qui va devoir
donner des instructions très claires
pour rassurer les français et pour
enrayer cette peur là qui plombent
actuellement tout l'effort de
redressement
merci beaucoup jean marc jean marc
sylvestre journaliste éditorialiste
économique pour rt france